people are afraid of confrontation right
that's what they're afraid of and so i
believe that you can sell without ever
having confrontation and you can do that
with what i like to call childlike
curiosity and so if someone says well my
husband's not going to approve that i'm
like why wouldn't he like huh that's so
interesting tell me more about that
rather than like all right let's like
your husband's an [ __ ] like that's
not gonna work because in arguments no
one wins right and so you're like why
would he think that because because i
would think that he wants what's best
for you right yeah he wants what's best
does he know you're struggling with this
right now well i mean yeah he knows i'm
struggling with it okay so he wants us
because he knows you're struggling with
it so why do you think he would be
opposed to solving something that that
you're currently struggling with would
he be happier if you continue to
struggle well no it's like well great
you make a joke and the light is
scenario then you close it right and so
i think childlike curiosity is the
immediate that you have to train because
people get defensive